je m'appelle jessica rousseau j'ai 31
ans et je suis depuis peu auto
entrepreneurs dans l'artisanat je suis
créatrice de bougies et fondant
parfaitement bien et en os au j'ai 32
ans je suis mécanicien automobile
[Musique]
prenez vraiment là pour vraiment pour
découvrir voir si ça nous plaît le haut
niveau et pourquoi pas découvrir autre
chose c'est jamais un coup de coeur
[Musique]
repartir à zéro sur de nouveaux paysages
nouvelle rencontre que tout recommencer
si ça nous plaît voir au niveau des
écoles de des services qui a aux
alentours et puis pourquoi pas après
chercher une maison on regarde quand on
se promène on regarde un bon cadre de
vie de nos paysages pour se promener en
famille
[Musique]
on est tous les deux en train de lancer
notre entreprise et puis on n'est pas
contre le fait de déménager réussir
professionnellement et je suis en tire
bien c'est une région qu'on connaissait
pas du tout donc on s'est dit que
c'était une belle opportunité de
découvrir
enfin on fait
la région est très jolie a beaucoup de
choses à faire les gens sont très
accueillants
donc pour l'instant le le cadre est
plutôt agréable
m
[Musique]